welcome to a special policy briefing
they consent of this policy the
Brookings Institution before we start
appreciate if you could turn your
cellphone's off
great idea as you're probably aware
yesterday the bulk of the remaining
Syrian forces pulled out of Lebanon and
tomorrow there will be an official
departure ceremony between the Lebanese
government and the representatives the
remaining representatives of Syrian
presence in Lebanon
I eventually guess that this is not
exactly what President Hafez al-assad
had in mind when he handed over power to
his second son Bashar al-assad more than
four years ago it's been a rough ride
for the younger Syrian leader and those
who have tried to deal with him as well
from domestic reformers to Western
statesmen and diplomats many have been
frustrated by the gap between the
expectations of the young Western
educated ophthalmologist and the
performance which at times seems to be
reminiscent of the British behavior of
the Syrian Baath Party of yesteryear
what exactly is going on in Damascus
that's the question that we brought
Flynt Leverett to the Saban Center to
answer and he has done so in this book
which is just being published this week
it's called inheriting Syria Bashar's
trial-by-fire available at your
bookstore today including the one
outside
we brought flint to write this book
because of
commitment to in-depth research and in
particular the application of
experienced policymakers to that task
flint himself has had decades of
experience in the US government as an
analyst and then a senior analyst at the
Central Intelligence Agency then as a
policy planner in the State Department
finally as senior director for Near East
affairs in the National Security Council
in the first Bush administration he
brings a wealth of knowledge and
experience to the challenge of trying to
decipher how Bashar al-assad and the
ruling Baath Party is coping with the
legacy of Hafez al-assad he will speak
today first about the book and his main
conclusions and then we're honored to
have two distinguished journalists sy
Hersh and James Bennett to open the
discussion sy Hersh is probably well
known to you all as one of America's if
not the premier investigative reporter
he first came to prominence in 1969 many
of you will remember as the man who
wrote the first account of the me Lai
massacre in south vietnam since then
he's gone on to break a number of
important stories as a result of his
extraordinary investigative work and
publish a number of books he worked for
the New York Times for some time during
the 70s and 80s he is now journalist for
The New Yorker magazine where he was the
first to break the story of the I will
grab prison
treatment by US soldiers and since then
has published his latest book the chain
of command the road from 9/11 to Abu
grave
James Bennett is currently a staff
writer for the Sunday magazine of the
New York Times he served with great
distinction as the New York Times
Jerusalem bureau chief from 2001 to 2004
and is an astute observer of the Middle
East scene so it's my pleasure to ask
Flint to give us a synopsis of the book
inheriting Syria I must say that I'm
biased of course but I think it's a it's
a fascinating read and I'm very proud
that we've been able to bring you Flint
to the Saban Center to produce this go
ahead thank you
Thank You Martin and let me add my own
words of thanks to psy her and James
Bennet for for coming out today for this
book launch I also want to take a moment
to thank a couple of other people first
of all I want to thank Martin it was
Martin really who gave me the idea of
writing this book and more than that he
gave me the material and institutional
resources to get started on it at a time
when I was making some very difficult
personal decisions about leaving
government service and I will always be
in Martin's debt for that if Martin is
the person without whom I couldn't have
started the project and I also want to
thank the person without whom I couldn't
have finished it and that's my wife
Hillary you really have to love someone
to live with him while he's writing a
book and I'm very pleased to have had
the chance to dedicate inheriting Syria
to to Hillary I wish I could say that
when I started working on this almost
two years ago that I had the strategic
genius to foresee that April 2005 would
be the ideal moment put out a book on on
Syria you know was ready four months ago
and I told Brookings press to sit on it
and sit on at the moment wasn't right
that wouldn't be entirely accurate and
I'm not too proud to accept dumb luck as
a source of good fortune but by whatever
means this book has come to be put out
now I think this is really a critical
moment for Syria it's a critical moment
both in terms of the strategic
challenges that Syria is facing and it's
also a critical moment I think in terms
of US policy toward Syria I want to talk
about each of those things for just a
moment first of all it seems to me this
is a critical time in terms of the
strategic challenges facing Syria as
I've given interviews and done speaking
engagements
I'm oftentimes asked if Bashar al-assad
is in charge in Syria and I usually
answer yes often there's a kind of
challenging follow-up well is he in
charge in the same way that his father
was in charge and to that I usually say
well of course not and why at this point
in his evolution as a national leader
would you expect him to have the same
level of authority that his father
enjoyed for the last 15 or so years that
he was President Hafez al-assad if you
look at his career didn't really become
the uncontested master of Syria and this
perceived brilliant player of the
regional game until at least a decade or
so into his presidency after he had gone
through a series of defining challenges
he established Syrian hegemony in
Lebanon he defended that hegemony
against both Israel and the United
States he put down a challenge to his
regime from Sunni fundamentalist and he
put down a challenge to his own position
from his brother as after that that he
was Hafez al-asad the Lion of Damascus
but not before Bashar not quite five
years into his presidency I don't think
has gone through those kinds of defining
challenges I think he is going through
one now and how he handles that defining
crisis will I think say a lot about his
future as a national leader and about
the future of Syrian politics and
Syria's regional position that's why I
say it's critical moment in terms of the
serious strategic situation I also think
it's a critical moment in terms of the
evolution of US policy towards Syria
since I left government two years ago
I've often criticized the Bush
administration for not having a Syria
policy during its first term in office
like its predecessors the Bush
administration has have a long list of
complaints about Syrian behaviors
support for terrorism pursuit of weapons
of mass destruction in Chapman II and
Lebanon so I was a not cooperating with
us goals in Iraq all these things we've
had a long list of complaints but we've
not had a policy if by policy you mean
an integrated set of public positions
diplomatic initiatives other measures
all rooted in a strategy for changing
Syrian behaviors that we think are
problematic now though I think the
administration may be inching toward a
policy but basically a policy of regime
change in Syria we certainly haven't
adopted a declaratory policy of regime
change but I think more and more people
in the administration are inclined
in that direction I think that the
administration has accepted an
assessment of Syrian politics that by
forcing Syria out of Lebanon this regime
is not going to be able to recover from
that blow and we'll start to unravel it
struck me a couple of weeks ago I
appeared on the NPR show fresh air and I
would really encourage you that the
interview is up on the Saban Center
website don't go and listen listen to me
fast forward to the end of the interview
when after I've been talking for a while
they put on Liz Dibble from the State
Department now Liz is a very experienced
officer someone that I worked with when
I was in government she's done public
diplomacy she served in Damascus she
certainly knows the talking points for
US policy toward Syria and what really
is striking is that after she's gone
through this long list of complaints
about Syrian behavior Terry Gross assert
well are you out to change Syrian
behavior or are you out to change the
Syrian regime and there is several
seconds of dead air
okay and gross keeps coming back at the
question two or three more times and Liz
won't give an answer now six months ago
if you'd asked the State Department
official if we were out to change Syrian
behavior out to change Syrian regime you
would have gone an unhesitating answer
that we were out to change Syrian
behavior nowadays at State Department
they're not sure that we're just out to
change Syrian behavior I think we are
kind of inching toward a regime change
posture and so for that reason I think
it's a critical moment terms of US
policy towards Syria so at this critical
moment I put out inheriting Syria and I
hope it does make a contribution to the
policy discussion the book from my
perspective has two objectives first of
all I wanted to provide an actionable
analytic portrait of Bashar al-assad as
a national leader this is something that
I think is very much needed if you look
at the really outstanding books that
have been written on Syria in the last
20 years you would certainly include the
political biographies of Hafez al-assad
by mishima OS and patrick seal but both
of those books are more than 15 years
old there have been some very good
writing on the israeli-syrian
negotiations by itamar robin ovitch by
dennis ross others the israeli scholar
yells is er wrote a nice book on the
last decade of Hafez his presidency but
there's really nothing out there on
Syrian politics and policymaking under
Bashar so I thought it was time that
something tried to fill that void and I
hope in Tara day inheriting Syria does
that the second objective of the
though is to take that actionable
analytics portrait developed in the book
and draw the implications for US policy
as you may have deduced I don't think
very much of the way that the Bush
administration has gone about trying to
deal with Syria and achieve US policy
objectives towards Syria I think there
is a smarter way of going about things I
said I think that there is a pressing
need for a more solid analytic
assessment of Syrian politics and
policymaking under Bashar one of the
things that strikes me at this critical
moment is that there really is a good
deal of analytic uncertainty and even
confusion about Syria with a focus on
Bashar's leadership in the book identify
what I think are the three dominant
perspectives that tend to govern our
discussion of Syria one I describe
Bashar as closeted reformer you know he
is the Western educated internet savvy
younger generation leader who recognizes
Syria's many problems wants to make
things better wants a better
relationship with the United States and
the West generally but is constrained by
a so called old guard a second
perspective I identify is Bashar as
loyal son in this image Bashar is really
a force for continuity in the system not
for change he is seen as a thoroughgoing
product of the system his father created
and he is very much
from this perspective part of the
problem in Syria not in any way part of
the solution and then the third
perspective I identify is Bashar as
neophyte or even in some more pejorative
formulations Bashar as as idiot in a
slate magazine article I found that the
subtitle
was the evil [ __ ] who's running area in
this image Bashar's presented as someone
who is too inexperienced ill-prepared
uninformed etc to carry out his
responsibilities as a national leader in
reality I think the picture of Bashar
has to be a more nuanced and mixed
picture in my view Bashar has genuine
reformist impulses he recognizes that
Syria has a lot of problems economically
socially politically and he wants things
to be different and better but I would
argue that his reformist impulses are
attenuated he doesn't have a
full-fledged vision for transforming
Syria people talk about his Western
education but let's keep in mind what
that experience really was it was a
little over a year in London in what we
in the United States would describe as
an ophthalmology residency program now
if any of you have had friends who went
to medical school and then went through
that kind of post Graduate Medical
Education you will know that first-year
residents don't have lives you know they
work and they get what sleep they can
and that is their life
Bashar himself told me when I asked him
about his experience in London he
himself said you know I got to know very
well the route between the hospital
where I worked and the flat where I
lived he says I still don't know London
very well ok yes he had some experience
in the West in a and essentially
technocratic field but let's not
overstate this it's not he wasn't doing
a PhD at LSE
okay so while he has reformist impulses
he doesn't have on his own I would say a
really thorough well elaborated vision
for transforming his country he does
indeed face constraints from the so
called old guard but I think here too
there's sometimes a caricature at work
when I was able to interview him for
this book I was this was certainly a
topic I wanted to ask him about but I
thought I'm gonna ease into this I'm
gonna be here for a while before I raise
the subject of the old guard but
literally within the first quarter hour
that I was with him he raised the
subject and I said all right mr.
president he raised a very interesting
topic what would you want people in the
United States in the West to understand
about your relationship with his
so-called old garden and he said he said
number of things but the most
interesting thing to me was he said
people need to understand that the old
guard is not just two or three guys who
occupy senior positions at the top of
the system the old guard is literally
thousands of mediocre and fossilised
those are his words mediocre and
fossilized bureaucrats who are
throughout the system and who have been
entrenched in their positions over years
and decades and have no interest in
doing anything in a different way
the old guard is also a private sector
that's a private sector really in name
only and exists in a kind of unhealthy
symbiosis with this entrenched
bureaucracy he said now you look at that
that's the old guard and that's a real
obstacle to change here
so he is constrained but the constraint
is not just two or three old guys at the
top it's more systemic than that the
charr is trying to find ways in my view
to work around the old guard both the
two or three guys at the top and this
more defuse an entrenched old guard in
the bureaucracy and I document in the
book how he is basically setting up his
own alternative network of technocrats
people with Western advanced degrees in
fields like economics computer science
business people who've had experience in
the private sector outside Syria or with
international institutions like the
World Bank and he is over time building
up a network of these people and placing
them in for the most part second-tier
positions in the Syrian system
occasionally he gets one up into a
ministerial level appointment and I
think he's trying to build up this
network over time another part of that
network and I it's part of the
confirmation for my argument that Bashar
really does have reformist impulses is
his wife Ozma I'm saying that's not only
because my own wife is here
I think hua band says a good deal about
him now the woman that Bashar chose to
marry and chose to marry over his
mother's objections which is not
insignificant in his cultural setting
that woman is the daughter of an
expatriate Syrian physician a
world-class interventional cardiologist
who's made his career in the night
kingdom she was born raised educated
entirely in the UK has a degree in
computer science from the University of
London went through the investment
banking training program at JP Morgan
worked at Deutsche Bahn and had been
admitted to the MBA program at Harvard
Business School at the time that Bashara
proposed to her now you may question
what it says about her judgment that she
gave up Harvard Business School to
accept that proposal but I'm wearing
seeing what that says about Bashar's
judgments that the person he selects to
be beside him on a daily basis is
someone who is going to bring exposure
to absolute world-class standards and
practices in the globalized economy of
the 21st century I find that a very
striking statement about him so he's
trying to develop this alternative
network of technocrats but I think he
still suffers from some pretty serious
capacity deficits he does not have
around him the range and depth of
technocratic expertise that he needs to
craft serious reform initiatives
particularly in the economy he himself
will admit this acknowledged this in
conversation that when he has tried to
do various sorts of reforms banking
reform introducing private banking for
example the process goes unnecessarily
slowly and the impact of it is reduced
because he doesn't have the kind of
expertise he needs to do things in a
systematic way so inevitably what he
does has this kind of ad-hoc and
inadequate or insufficient quality to it
so if I think about Bashar as a national
leader you know the picture is I think
needs to be more subtle than the
perspectives that tend to dominate our
discussion of Syria will allow for
reformist impulses but they're
attenuated doesn't have a full vision
trying to develop an alternative network
of advisors and experts around him but
he still doesn't have the technocratic
capacity he needs to move things forward
in the way that I think he would like he
is constrained by the old guard I think
on the whole he does not want to have a
confrontation with the old guard he
would basically prefer to work around
them and I think he also assumes that
biology is on his side he will turn 40
this year you know I think if Syrian
politics played out his natural course
you know he's not term limited I don't
think he has to worry about losing an
election anytime soon I think the way he
sees reform unfolding is over a very
long period of time a decade or more but
the real question is given the strategic
challenges that he's facing does he
really have that kind of time
and that brings us back to the notion of
this being a very critical moment I
think that the administration is
embarked on a course where the risk of
unintended consequences is very high the
risk of unintended consequences is
certainly high in terms of what could
happen in Lebanon but I will let others
talk about that today and we can return
to it in questions if you like but I
think it's also unintended in terms of
what could happen
in Syria I said the administration is
inching toward a regime change posture I
don't think we're gearing up to invade
Syria don't take me you know the wrong
way at this point I don't think we're
gearing up for that but I think the
administration believes it can achieve
regime change on the cheap you know as I
said you know the idea being if we push
Syria out of Lebanon the Assad regime
can't recover from that blow I actually
don't think that's the case I think this
regime is more resilient than that and I
actually take seriously a scenario in
which if four months five months six
months down the road it's clear that
Bashar al Assad can still set the outer
limits for Lebanese policy on the issues
that really matter to Syria I think that
Bashar could conceivably emerge as a
stronger figure domestically and
regionally if on the other hand he is
seen as someone who has squandered an
important strategic resource for Syria
that could have consequences for him at
home even if we were able to bring down
the Assad regime on the cheap it's not
really clear to me what interests of the
United States are being served by that
you know what would follow in a society
that is as complicated as serious and I
would argue that Syrian society is at
least as complicated as Lebanese society
or as rocky society what would follow
the collapse of the Assad regime would
be certainly chaotic and what might
emerge or what would be likely to emerge
from that chaos would be in my view
heavily Islamist in character and I'm
not really sure
American interests would be served in
that scenario I think there is a better
way to achieve American policy
objectives toward Syria and that is
through a strategy of what I describe as
conditional engagement it's not rocket
science it's carrots and sticks in a
previous era we used to call it
diplomacy my experience with this
administration is they find diplomacy a
very challenging undertaking and they've
certainly not in my view tried
strategically rooted diplomacy with
Syria I think that we could make real
progress toward our objectives with
Syria through a carrots and sticks
approach I think that Bashar wants to
make a strategic understanding with the
United States I think he realizes this
is critical to his own interests in
reforming Syria and I think he is open
to making in effect a bargain that
addresses our most important concerns
but he wants to know what is in it for
him
he said to me very clearly on this point
Syria is a state not a charity if we are
going to give something up I need to
know what we're going to get in return
and that is a conversation that he has
been unable to have with this
administration we make demands of Syria
and I think by and large the demands are
justified and warranted but we do not
spell out what is in it for Syria to
cooperate with us
and therefore we don't get very far I
think if we were prepared to have a
serious strategic conversation with
Bashar and apply a keratin 6 approach we
could do much better at achieving our
policy objectives than on the course
we're barked on now so I lay out that
argument in the book and if you haven't
bought the book you can pick it up today
at the Brookings bookstore I encourage
everyone to read it and thanks to
everyone for coming thank you
sy Hersh had a chance to talk to Bashar
al-assad also yeah I have a problem I
actually was seeing him right at the
time the critical time in early February
the problem I have is I'm still doing
work on it so I have to you know I'm a
professional journalist but I have some
things I can say without getting into a
lot of details first of all I found I
read his book going this Syria I read an
early version of it and it is it's
absolutely you can understand why he's
not at the White House absolutely
balanced reason view of what to do and
as I said I thought I said what what
Flynn said at the end of course is you
know he is willing to play he's willing
to deal I'm always reluctant to tell you
I can't tell how nice he is he's a very
open friendly almost disingenuous person
well of course and I think it's real and
and so any journalist will tell you
where the salt at that are you always
have to discount the affection you feel
for somebody because he is a warm person
there are some wonderful ironies about
all this and to get back to the real
world I'm always amused by democracy in
Lebanon being touted by the United
States since let's see I RCA was fixing
elections in Lebanon before but Bashar
was born you know promoting the marinus
and the 50s you know some of you know of
some of you in the government probably
know firsthand ray clothes and all the
stuff that was going on then there was
an awful lot of stuff going on so we're
not innocent in all of this I'm just
I'll just take us back to some of the
questions that that
that fascinate me about the current
event what's going on now is how early
we really don't know who killed her ari
I had a friend in the government there
are some people some of the people in
the Oh cons like the chap to me I don't
know why torture me probably but anyway
I had a friend say to me it doesn't
matter why are you worrying about the
fact there's no empirical evidence for
who killed them there isn't I don't like
the UN report at all the Fitzhugh report
I mean if you go back and look at the
same report he wrote in Kosovo he wrote
one that was also you can read between
the lines in the report it doesn't
establish anything and Hariri and death
was just like Ronald Reagan much more
wonderful than her Arian life you know
when I when I knew about her Ari it was
always about the enormous amount of
money he was peddling into a Chirac and
into other people his representation of
the Saudis not that he didn't have some
ideas and not that he wasn't a key
player in the rebuilding of Lebanon but
the godlike affectation that he has in
death wasn't there in life her Aries
death as somebody to come and said to me
he said sigh worrying worrying about it
it doesn't matter what the reality is
it's Syria did it that's all we say and
that's all the world wants to believe
and that's it Syria did it whether
Bashar the big issue is did Bashar doing
it did he know it or was it done by
kazowie and that is is some of the
intelligence people behind his back in
Lebanon and I don't think that is the
big issue I think the real question is I
don't think we should rush to judgment
on all these things and we shouldn't be
so quick to rule out anybody
investigating it as corrupt as we have
except for the UN so it's it's for me
it's an open question I do think that in
death Harare the best thing that has
happened the French US relationships has
been the death of Harare you know and so
now you have and you can't discount you
know in all foreign policy discussions
you know as Tip O'Neill once said all
politics is local
you can't discuss the friendship
regardless of its basis between Harry
and Chirac and Chirac's Veneman right
now towards a bashar there's a sure are
because really very angry his his he
believes that that Bashar or the Syrian
government of whether it as evidence or
not is directly responsible for the
death of his longtime friend and
longtime benefactor
another issue that by the way Flint gets
into a few times in his books in his
book is very interesting he does fun if
it does get into the notion that Harare
is had another life in terms of this
Paola
and and so I think that colors are our
policy in a nutshell I don't think there
is much given our policy I think as not
surprisingly I think the essential
American policy is it's been stated to
me is that Bashar E is Saddam Hussein
for many of the people the main players
in this White House he's simply you know
not literally but figuratively he's
somebody that in their view must go will
it happen there's so many imponderables
were really in an amazing situation now
in which the game plan against the
initial White House game plan further
when we doing the Middle East which i
think is very real was very real they
got a bonus with her Aries death but the
basic game plan involves Syria and Iran
obviously and it's pretty much up in the
air no matter what they tell you no
matter how much good stuff they want to
spin about the election process and all
that they're we're in real trouble in in
Iraq and and the real the real issue and
one of the big focal points for us is
obviously you can't control what's going
on Iraq right now in their view without
controlling Iran and so do we go
frontally to Iran what do we do I think
Syria inevitably is in second place or a
backburner position in the and hegemony
hegemon oil instincts of this government
I think they have to figure out what to
do with Iran as long as I'm with Iran
there there's no real safety in Iraq I
think of their view they see a direct
connection between none of it you all
read you all know what Abdul has been
saying publicly in Jordan this and the
Saudis are saying and certainly the
Egyptians are saying nobody wants the
spread of our reigning robber ever an
Arabian revolution Iranian Revolution
into the south into south into Iraq
nobody in this government does so
there's a lot of issues there will they
end up choosing to decide to isolate
Syria one one attractive thing in
talking to people about getting rid of
Syria of course or getting rid of this
regime is then you isolate Iran more you
have it surrounded by potential enemies
do they think that's an impossible
position no I think there I think they
think he's gonna fall from inside and I
think that's that's my sense I'm talking
to people that he's gonna erode his own
position and I I don't know how much
we're really gonna do overtly the
tragedy of all of this in terms of as as
Flint gets into in terms of what we
could achieve that would be useful in
the Middle East and we could achieve an
awful lot with carrot and sticks I even
think in terms of Hamas and jihad and
support he's an Orientalist in a way if
we don't go facially or frontally with
him we could probably it could have
accomplished much more and we've also
he's made a lot of steps in the right
direction but he doesn't get rewarded
and they'll forget you know this whole
process began with 9/11 and Syria was a
very very valuable much people in the
sea I will tell you an extremely value
valuable ally in the first months first
six months the first year of our war
against against terrorism because of
their long-standing you know they this
was a country that like Iraq didn't have
much use for jihadism the Muslim
Brotherhood and the files they turned
over I think my understanding was were
in if not the hundreds of thousands of
files and an enormous help in the
beginning to us as we began sort of
belatedly to figure out what's going on
in that world in the world of terrorism
and so we butchered that relationship
even though Bashar has been I could just
tell you turn the other cheek at
enormous stupidities by our CIA in
dealing with their intelligence
I mean enormous confounding sort of
stupidities he's maintained still would
be willing to maintain a
ship i he doesn't get anything for it
and he did provide it I can tell you
again specific information that saved
American lives in the first year of the
war on terrorism in other places in the
world including in the West he had
information that was incredibly valuable
to us and was dealt with in such a way I
think there was a split between the
intelligence agencies and this
administration but the overwhelming
picture is very bleak because we've got
a government run by people that do not
want to look at the world that Flynt
Leverett describes the world of nuance
as he said in balance and
carrot-and-stick and long term there's a
short term goal here that I think defies
logic the five sensibility and his
American policy thank you
one of the interesting things and
perhaps we can get into it in the
discussion is that on the one hand
Bashar has as you pointed out helped out
in the war on al-qaeda but on the other
hand he has enabled the insurgency in
Iraq to to have support and in some
cases direction from Syria hold on
there's a lot of there's a lot of
controversy about the extent to which of
that exists there is I mean it's it's in
the reporting I've done recently I've
had a lawful lot of people who once had
high officials of position the
government of recently left telling me
on the record I haven't written it yet
that in fact he's been a restraining
force you know very often yes there are
many many former Baathists living in
Syria there's no question but I'll tell
you right now they're all over the world
they're all over the Middle East as
certainly as many in Jordan UAE
everybody's getting the hell out of
there
anybody with any money so not that
you're wrong he but the general notion
that he has been an invaluable Ally of
the insurgency I don't think is so I
think there's a lot of restraints on it
I don't know what you think what do you
think Jim I'm not remotely qualified to
talk to you about Syria certainly not as
qualified as these gentlemen so I've
kind of assigned my self the role of
starting off the questioning I have read
Flint's book and I congratulate him on
it both on the book itself and on his
timing because just at the moment a lot
of us have a lot of questions about
Syria he has fortuitously driven up with
many answers and a sense for the
complexity and nuance of Syrian politics
how the world looks from Damascus and
our own relationship to Syria that's
largely missing I think right now from
the discussion in this country I have
done a fair amount of thinking about
about Syria's role in the region
particularly from the perspective of the
israeli-palestinian calm
and sort of from that base that'll try
to ask a few questions and and get the
conversation going
Flint and your in your remarks just now
you refer to the test of President
Assad's success or failure and managing
the withdrawal from Lebanon being his
capacity to set the outer limits of
Lebanese policy can you talk a little
bit more in a little more detail about
what that means what what's his big fear
or worry about this withdrawal and what
tools does he have available to him to
prevent that fear from being realized I
think if you look historically the
biggest challenge that that Bashar's
father faced to Syrian interests in
Lebanon came in 1982 when in the
aftermath of the Israeli invasion of
Lebanon Israel the United States several
of our European allies supported the
installation of Lebanese government that
was prepared to sign a separate peace
treaty with Israel in fact sign such a
treaty it was in the aftermath of that
treaty signing that Hezbollah really
emerged as a very important and potent
paramilitary force in Lebanon carrying
out terrorist attacks against the US
embassy in Beirut against the Marine
Barracks the French ambassador in
Lebanon was was killed and as a result
of those attacks the United States
withdrew its forces from Lebanon the
Israelis retreated into what became the
security zone in southern Lebanon and
the Israeli Lebanese peace treaty was
abrogated in 1984 I think that's really
the worst case from a Syrian perspective
that you could get in the aftermath of
parliamentary elections in Lebanon
whenever they happen you could get a
government organized by the current
opposition and there are opposition
figures in Lebanon I don't know that
this is a dominant you know thread of
opposition argument but there are those
in Lebanon who will say things like well
you know Lebanon doesn't really have a
dispute with Israel we could make the
forty-nine Armistice line a border
between Israel and Lebanon and sign a
peace treaty with them tomorrow I think
the first thing the first and foremost
thing the bashar wants to keep from
happening is just that scenario
to make sure that lebanon does not sign
a separate peace with israel i think he
will have levers of influence that he
can use to keep that from happening
I think Hezbollah will be an important
leader influence there will still be
other Pro Syrian players and factions in
Lebanese politics so I think that is
really the first and foremost interest
that he is he is out to protect I think
there is a range of economic interest
that he will want to try to try to
preserve and I think to some degree
market forces are going to help him do
that a lot of the recent reporting and
analysis it sounds as if the Syrian
Lebanese economic relationship is a
one-way relationship that operates
entirely to Syria's benefit I think the
reality is more complicated than that
there are a lot of ways in which
important people in Lebanon have
benefited from that relationship and I
don't mean entirely through through
corruption or illicit kinds of ties
Syria is Lebanon's most important export
market if it wants to be able to Lebanon
wants to be able to send it send its
exports out to the wider Arab world it's
only overland routes are through Syria
so I think they're going to be ways that
the shark and as I said set outer limits
on the most important aspects of
Lebanese policy
and keep the more important aspects of
the economic relationship going do you
think lovely or both you guys on this
question that that the administration
you spoke about the administration and
visiting some process of unraveling here
that that but I'm very unclear on what
the precise mechanism would be do you
think that you they actually think in
terms of pushing a new Lebanese
government towards signing some sort of
peace agreement with Israel or sealing
the border economically that is with
Syria as ways to start pushing the
regime over how would they actually go
about about accomplishing this kind of
unraveling well the the causal logic is
also unclear to me which is one reason I
don't think this is a particularly smart
way to plan policy on our part I think
you could you could argue there there
are a couple of dynamics in play that
that people in the administration who
would who would like to see the Assad
regime unravel but they may be counting
on one is an argument that if Syria
loses its position in Lebanon if for
example all the hundreds of thousands of
Syrian workers who've been employed in
Lebanon have to come back that this is
going to put such pressure on an already
strained Syrian economy it will increase
popular discontent and you can get a
popular a popular uprising I think that
may be one causal mechanism that they
are looking at I think in other causal
mechanism they may be looking at is the
idea that if Bashar is seen by those
around him in the power structure as
having squandered Syria's position in
Lebanon that people will start to wonder
if Bashar is really their best bet it
could start different factions in the
power structure sort of competing with
one another and over time the regime
isn't able to maintain its cohesion I
don't think either either of those
scenarios is
particularly likely I'm just interested
in a couple of things I'm always done
every all the anecdotal evidence I have
from people who travel to Damascus and
my own personal perceptions which are
useless when it comes to this is that
he's popular Bashar is popular he's seen
but many people in in in Syria in the
streets in the people you just don't see
that much that much evidence of any
significant he's not very popular among
the old guard some of the old wealthy
you know Mercedes and BMW crowd they see
him is not very not very strong at least
some of those I know and have known some
of them talk about him as as somebody
whose time is short but I among in the
street he's part I just I don't know how
how much it means I also think there's a
lot of basis for believing that he
seriously wanted to talk to Israel very
much on the Golan Heights we wanted to
renew those talks and he has said the
same thing I've been told in Washington
I I before I talked to him I told it I
have been told in Washington that the
was the White House was very very active
in telling Cherone which is hard to do
anyway but telling him not to
participate in these talks I know if you
heard that so the pressure was against
participating in the talks whether
Israel wanted to or not came from
Washington the Washington's view was
this is at the time of the Iraqi
incursion a war don't do it right now
that is that correct that's why I
understand that's his understanding - he
said that - it's very interesting on
that point I think that Bashar is
positioned on on resuming peace
negotiations has evolved over the time
that he's been president and I try to
chart that evolution in the book but I
think you're right basically from
roughly the time of the Iraq war shortly
thereafter Bashar has been saying pretty
steadily pretty consistently that he he
wants to resume peace negotiations with
with Israel and this has started a very
lively debate in the Israeli national
security establishment very serious
credible people like the head of Israeli
military intelligence their country's
chief intelligence officer of the former
IDF chief-of-staff eivol argued that
this is serious that
really is prepared to do a deal with
Israel I think it's a deal under the
right conditions from Bashar's
perspective but still he's ready to do a
deal and that Israel should pursue this
it would be in Israel's interest to
conclude a peace with Syria on the other
hand there are those in the professional
national security establishment in
Israel who are not so sure that Bashar
really wants to do a deal generally
these are the people who also argue
during the 90s that Hafez al-assad never
really wanted to do a deal that the
Syria track was all from a Syrian
perspective some kind of charade I mean
I believe that Hafez wanted to do a deal
in the 90s I believe that Bashar would
with the right conditions do a deal now
but it's kind of moot because I think
sharone looking at what he has on his
plate he doesn't want to have to deal
with the domestic politics of
negotiating a peace with Syria at the
time that he's dealing with a lot of
domestic problems in connection with
implementing is his Gaza disengagement
plan and I think you're right to the
extent that there were people serious
people in the Israeli government who
were arguing in favor of resuming peace
talks with Syria the administration has
been telling him don't do this now and
this is one favor that road is willing
to do for but but let me just say the
question Martin's gonna ask I bet what
about Hezbollah what about support for
Hezbollah what about support from Hamas
what about support for Islamic jihadism
was there much play was there a chance
to really get Bechard to do something on
those issues he would say and he has
said to me why do you ask me to do
things in public I can't do you know
what I'm saying this Orientalism why
does it why why are both sides talking
again you know in a funny way they are
in other words we want him to do
something he can't do and he wants
something from us we can't do in a way
you know that at least this
administration can't but it was there do
you think there was a chance that we
could have and this is before the Gaza
Strip these talks began the talk about
Israel was was was almost 2 years ago
before the Gaza in the
ago she Asians got serious there was a
time then Elliott Abrams being the
pointment and and so I understand in
telling the Israelis not to go ahead and
I don't know if that's your
understanding Martin but but in any case
let's just say there was no enthusiasm
in the White House for taking this
challenge up but could they have gotten
a deal from him could they have gotten
something a cutback in support you know
the big issue is going to be obviously
Hezbollah and in the next the next year
yeah look I I think we all know if
there's going to be a peace deal between
Israel and Syria what the deal looks
like Bashar is going to have to get
something that he can plausibly portray
as full Israeli withdrawal from the
Golan he is perfectly prepared to talk
about security arrangements DMZ limited
force zones third-party monitoring other
things like that to ensure from an
Israeli perspective that the Golan
couldn't be remilitarization of
relations and I think Bashar understands
that as part of that deal you know
support for groups like Hamas and
Islamic Jihad would have to be stopped
and I think he also understands that
Hezbollah's disarmament in Lebanon would
be would be part of part of the package
the the kept his fingers to make that
happen
though I wouldn't say snap his fingers
but as part of an overall settlement in
which Syria and Lebanon were getting
peace treaties with Israel I think it
would be understood that the Lebanese
armed forces would be disarming
Hezbollah and at least before Syrian
forces withdrew from Lebanon Syrian
forces would backfill the positions that
the LAF would have to give up in order
to go into the south and and take care
of that Hezbollah weapons caches look in
your disappears the crux of the of the
problem you know the three of us at
least
each individually had a chance to talk
with President Assad and I think we've
all come away with the same conclusion
my sky talks a good game about reform
and peace with Israel but when you leave
the room and and you look at what
happens he doesn't seem to have the
ability to follow through in my case my
experience with him was he explained
very he was very candid in the same way
as he was with you I terms of explaining
his problems and very clear about what I
thought was a fairly from his
perspective fairly shrewd strategy which
was that he was going to make peace with
Israel and cooperate with the United
States over Iraq and his assumption
unspoken was that we'd leave him alone
in Lebanon and but he didn't follow
through on making peace with Israel and
it's not it's not enough just to say
well you know Iran didn't respond or
Bush didn't respond there are plenty of
things that he could have done if he was
serious about making peace I think he
was serious but there's a lack of
follow-through if he was serious about
stopping the support for the insurgency
that was coming from Iraq from Syria
into Iraq he could have done a lot more
than that
so isn't really the case that your
analysis of his of his reform
capabilities which is quote constrained
applies also to his foreign policy that
that he's constrained there too and that
what you've got is nice guy who wants to
do the right thing but isn't able to do
it I think there's a bigger question is
it particularly in terms of the sporran
policy it gets back to that line I
quoted about how you know if he's gonna
give something up he needs to know what
he's gonna get in return
youyou asked as I asked about and you
asked about what he's doing in terms of
the insurgency in Iran look I think it's
pretty clear at a minimum that Syria is
not doing everything it could to
constrain the flow of weapons people
money etc from Syria to support the
Iraqi
in his 40 rocky insurgents okay
periodically Syria does something to
show that it could be helpful you know
it affects the turnover of some
important former regime people it
cooperates with us on on some aspect of
the funding problem you know their
number of things that he does
periodically to show I could be helpful
here but he is still waiting to
understand from us if I if I am helpful
in a sustained way here if I in a sense
give up this card that I have what is it
that you're going to do for me and it's
a particularly unfortunate mismatch of
diplomatic styles or perspectives
because he's looking to have it spelled
out for him
before he really commits what are you
going to get in return and he's dealing
with an American administration that has
basically decided as a point of
principle and employment policy that it
will not spell out for him what he could
get if he cooperates and so therefore we
are in the situation where you know he
says these things indicates that he
would be prepared to move down certain
paths but then there is no real there is
no real movement because in my view on
the diplomatic context isn't created
okay let's go to my goodness questions
please make sure to identify yourselves
and ask questions ambassador Coutu what
wait for the microphone microphone
oh just yelled head a masterful
presentation that would could critique
good questioning from the panelists it
seems to me that there's been a
symbiotic relationship between President
Bashar al-assad and the old guard and I
don't know if you'd agree but basically
besides having the name my son father's
chosen heir whether it was ever admitted
or not
Bashar as you noted married well as you
know he is a attractive man and his
personal characteristics as we've all
known from meeting him he can go to the
Capitals he or he could go to the
capitals of York would be well received
he could go to he could go to Rome he
could go to Rome he could go to London
Paris Berlin and be be well received in
all those capitals and even learn some
PR while he was there but right now it
appears that the administration intends
as psy indicated to hold him responsible
for the murder of Hariri and give him
the arafat treatment since he is not
known to be particularly known to be a
tough guy at a time when there's a need
to keep you know if you're worried that
the u.s. is up to something and you can
exaggerate their ability to be
successful
the question is might elements of the
old guards start to look at Bashar as
having exhausted his usefulness to them
if he is no long if we can bring if the
US administration can bring Europe
around to their point of view is on in
terms of isolating Bashar I mean the
Turkish president broke ranks recently
but he's the only one I know that did
and then how do things look internally
in Syria yeah that's a that's a very
good question I will address it I just
wanted to say
I'm not sure I entirely accept the
premise of the question in that I think
that the current unity between the u.s.
and the major European allies on this
issue could well decrease in coming
weeks let's assume you know as of
tomorrow Syrian troops are out let's
assume at some point in the next few
weeks we have Lebanese parliamentary
elections I think then that the next
issue that's going to come up is going
to be well what about Hezbollah what's
its role in Lebanese politics does it
keep its guns etc and I think there you
have some real potential for the US and
Europe to go back on separate separate
paths so I'm not so sure that the
current unity is gonna last for very
long but that aside let me take the
premise of your question yeah if Bashar
is seen is not really able to deliver in
terms of cultivating a better position
for Syria in Europe at least if not in
the United States could he be seen as
less useful from the standpoint of the
old guard it's it's possible but then
they're still left with the question
assuming that they begin to question the
Shara's value to them they have to have
an alternative and my own sense is they
don't really have a ready alternative to
propose to put into Bashar's place they
certainly I don't think any of the
people who had senior positions under
Bashar's father could step in and and
play that role if you were gonna look
for people of a younger generation I
think you would probably have to look
within the Assad family you would still
be talking about an Assad regime just
maybe a different Assad and in that
context I guess the two possibilities
that people mentioned most are first of
all Bashar's
brother-in-law his sister's wife Asif
jelka sister's husband sorry Asif shall
cought who is now the head of Syrian
military intelligence
the other possibility that people
identify is Bashar's younger brother
Maher al-asad I mean people talk about
them as possible alternatives to Bashar
but I don't know that we have any you
know evidence at this point that they're
really willing to play that game I mean
in the past there is a precedent Hafez
al-assad was challenged most
significantly by his own brother Refaat
and he was challenged at a time of real
personal weakness and since the office
had had a heart attack he was laid up in
bed and it's in that context that his
brother Refaat mounted a challenge to
his position I think Bashar has
certainly challenged now but he's
challenged strategically I don't think
he's challenged personally and so I mean
we can we can identify those as
possibilities if the old guard began to
look around for an alternative maybe
they could look within the within the
family but I don't think we have any
evidence right now that either Maher or
Asif shall [ __ ] is really inclined to to
play that sort of game in the middle of
journalists I am a Syrian for the last
28 he is writing about Syria it's the
basic question which I really want to
ask you mr. liver that in Syria they
don't believe that you know turning a
republic into a monarchy can happen
without you know superpower consent I
mean the North Korean paradigm cannot be
repeated again and again and there are
now Libya Yemen and you know count you
can count many Arab country waiting for
this paradigm if you are pretty
chick now that engagement you know
conditional engagement with a what an
Arab Academy is called the gem lakiya
you know a republic monarchy you know /
if that's you know giving like green
lights to other dictators and a Fratelli
regime that they can really you know
turn Republic into monarchy and have the
blessing of the United States and have
the condition and engagement with them
okay when I argue in favor of a strategy
of conditional engagement I try to make
clear in the policy chapter that I think
that this is also the best way for
trying to promote liberalisation and
greater openness in in Syria because for
me conditional engagement would have a
couple of dimensions it would involve
this kind of carrots and sticks
strategic bargaining with the regime but
it also entailed more direct engagement
with Syrian civil society than we've
done so far and I think that it's one of
the ways in which if you engage Bashar
in this way you can actually empower him
to pursue internal reform at a somewhat
faster pace than he would in the absence
of of that engagement I don't think it's
you know making a deal with a dictator
and allowing him to stay a dictator I
think it's basically a process of
engagement in which US strategic
concerns are met or addressed but in
which you also create dynamics in which
which are more favorable to reform and
to liberalisation inside Syria I don't
think it's an either/or proposition
we heard from a caesarian the
journalists we hear from a Lebanese
journalist now Jordan actually the
question is I'm curious whether you can
provide us with a scenario of what
happened on the pull at Syrian decision
to pull out from Lebanon who took the
decision the president the old guard
were they in together on this and but
really my real question is who in the
administration is pushing the
administration on this very
short-sighted policy vis-a-vis Syria
okay is it the new Conservatives I've
just loved it everybody uses let me take
the second question first administration
dynamics I think there's both a push
from within and a push from from outside
the push from within is coming from if
you want to call you refer to them
generically it's neoconservatives okay I
don't I don't resist that language I
think you're talking about civilians in
the office of the Secretary of Defense
people around Vice President Cheney who
really have believed almost since the
beginning of the administration that
this was a particularly of serious that
that serious hegemony in Lebanon was so
important to the Assad regime that if he
could find a way to push on it this
would give you important leverage over
the Syrian regime I know for a fact I
mean I know from personal experience
that secretary Rumsfeld believes this
very much
they basically believes it from the time
that he was President Reagan's middle
east end boy presiding over the collapse
of the first term Reagan
administration's policy in Lebanon and
the withdrawal of US forces from Lebanon
you know exactly why that's the lesson
he learned from that experience was
never clear to me but it is very much
the lesson he he took from his time as
Reagan's middle east end point so I
think you've had a core of people in the
administration who really from the
beginning have seen pushing on Lebanon
as a way of pushing on on Syria they've
been making this argument for a long
time but they through
what I assume is coincidence why I think
is coincidence basically were able to
match up with the external source of
pressure and this is kind of ironic
particularly when you look at the cast
of people in the administration within
the administration making this argument
they're their biggest support from
outside the administration has come from
president chirac of France President
Chirac had a very long and close
personal friendship association with
Prime Minister Hariri a lot of people in
France who will tell you that Hariri was
a significant financial supporter for
sure ox political career and when Bashar
al-asad began to resist some of her
Erie's policy initiatives in Lebanon
after her earring returned his prime
minister by the time of the summer of
2004
you know Chirac was willing to take
French policy in a direction that wanted
to put pressure on Syria over Lebanon
and its really that intersection of
neo-cons in the administration and
French policy that gives you UN Security
Council resolution 1559 in the summer of
2004 now I actually thought 1559 was a
good idea because it did give us some
real leverage over Syria on something
that the Syrian leadership took as
important my complaint about the way
we've used 1559 particularly since Prime
Minister Hariri was assassinated is that
we have used it not as a source of
leverage to change Syrian behavior on
things that really matter to US
interests like the insurgency in Iraq
like support for anti Israeli
Palestinian terrorist groups we have
used it basically as a way of driving
Syrian forces
out of Lebanon and that has become the
be all and end all of our Syria policy
at this point and I think that's a
strategically shallow the project okay
please o withdraw sorry is every
indication I have is that that President
Assad took the decision to do that let
me just say one thing the same week that
la hoon was extended Ben Ali and Tunisia
despite being warned by secretary Powell
declared himself president for life and
Tunisia we didn't seem to be bothered by
that
Jeff Steinberg with the IR magazine the
second event that I guess is also a big
plus for the timing of your book release
is the controversy over the appointment
of John Bolton to the UN position and
one of the things that I recall was a
controversy about a year and a half ago
between the CIA and Bolton though over a
speech and an intelligence assessment
are we in another spin cycle on Syria
similar to Iraq visa vie intelligence
assessments and how they may be used we
may be I hope that people learn some
lessons from from the debacle of pre-war
intelligence on Iraq but you know
assuming learning curves is always a
little bit dangerous
look to my mind on Syrian WMD and I lay
this out in the book I feel very
confident even in a post you know post
Iraq environment I feel very confident
about saying the things that I've said
which are consistent with US government
representations about Syria's chemical
weapons capabilities and its scud
missile force I think we have absolutely
solid information for making the kinds
of statements we make on weaponize CW
agent and Scud missiles I do not believe
the case is there on on nuclear and I
don't think there's any evidence there
of significance indicating off
BW capability I mean BW is and it's such
an inherently murky area because of the
dual use nature of pharmaceutical and
biotechnology you know lots of people
that could have offensive BW
capabilities and we would we wouldn't be
able to say with great reliability that
they had it
I guess it's theoretically possible the
Syrians have it but I don't know that we
really have the evidence to indicate
that they have it the nuclear stuff
people occasionally will will try to say
that Syria's you know somehow pursuing
covertly a nuclear weapons program after
the disclosure of the AQ Khan Network
there's been a lot of speculation that
Syria was somehow a customer of that
Network I haven't seen any real evidence
of that and I will dis note that as
recently as late last year Mohammed Al
borrowed I was saying that there is no
you know Syria cooperates the IAEA
inspection process and that there is no
evidence of any kind of illicit or
covert Syrian nuclear activity from
please no sorry
plink calidad from alarm I'd like to
thank you very much for your
presentation I just had a question for
you through your interviews with
President Bashar Assad did you give an
explanation why isn't he
pushing at all towards the internal
political reform process I mean Syria
until now remains to be almost among the
few Arab countries which doesn't really
have like plural priority of newspapers
I mean doesn't even consider like a
limited experience like Egypt in the
late 70s you know with a few political
parties and a few Free Press thank you I
said that President Assad has a kind of
gradualist approach to reform you know
he views this as a process it plays out
over many years I think probably longer
than a decade he also in a way views it
is going on in in phases or at least on
different levels I think in his view
economic reform definitely gets primacy
that you need to work on the economy
first some people have described this as
a Chinese model of economic reform and
whether you want to call it the Chinese
model or not I think it's something that
he very much believes in that economic
reform gets put on a primacy I think the
second aspect of reform is social reform
which in his view largely means the
attenuation of sectarian identity in
Syrian society and the development of
civil society in Syria which basically
means organizations associations other
kinds of fora in which people define
their identities in some way other than
by religious sect
okay that's essentially what civil
society is about and political reform is
for him the last part of the reform
process and he's very explicit about
saying you don't want to move on that
too early otherwise you get an outcome
like we got in Algeria in 1992 now you
know could he move faster on political
reform yes he could I think it's going
to be very interesting to see what
is announced at the upcoming bath party
Congress this June if he laid down a
marker in his own speech to the Syrian
Parliament on March 5th in connection
with Lebanon that this reform that this
party Congress was going to be an
occasion for significant reform
announcements certainly political
cognoscenti and Damascus are looking to
this meeting as a potentially important
event where some I mean perhaps changes
in the party law allowing parties
outside the national progressive front
to form I mean I don't know what's gonna
get announced but I you know that I
think that'll be something to look for
in June unfortunately we're going to
have to bring this session to a close I
apologize to everybody who wanted to ask
questions the being noon we need to
finish up here I have a close out among
McLaughlin s closeout question which is
in ten years time well Bashar al-assad
still be President of Syria and will
Syria have a peace treaty with Israel
yeah I think the odds are ten years from
now if I had to bet money up or down I
bet the fish are will still be President
of Syria I'm less sure about the peace
treaty with Israel okay I want to thank
sy Hersh James Bennett for participating
in this discussion and especially Flint
for all the hard work you did to produce
this and such a timely basis thank you
all very much for coming